this video is proudly sponsored by
Squarespace stick around until the end
of the video to learn
[Music]
more solid snake is a oneman army cloned
from the greatest soldier who ever lived
he shows in the games repeatedly that
with stealth and cunning you can
overcome overwhelming Firepower and odds
overwhelming power and yet in the gym
power is 99% of what most of us train so
for this video I spoke with exmilitary
personnel with functional trainers whove
worked closely with Special Operations
forces to find out how we can move and
how we can train like Solid Snake
because I'm the bioneer and I've got
issues
Ninja
so how do we move stealthily and without
being seen well one of the first things
we need to consider is body control and
awareness being aware of your body in
space propri reception but also able to
control your limbs and move slowly and
precisely which requires a different
kind of strength than being forceful and
explosive so for example if you're
jumping down from a small height and you
want to land this quietly as possible
this is about absorbing the impact by
bending your joints and gradually
providing that antagonistic resistance
to slow yourself down not to completely
blunt the movement which will create a
noise but to gradually absorb the impact
in the sound which is how we should be
moving anyways if we want to make sure
that we're not placing too much strain
and impact on our joints so practicing
to start with jumping and Landing
quietly is a great way to start out
moving more quietly and precisely but
it's also a really good practice in
general Beyond this we also need to be
aware of our bodies when walking when
moving because in a similar manner the
way we place our feet down of course is
going to have a big impact on the sound
of our footfall several groups practice
a variety of quiet movement techniques
the military use crawls like the monkey
run and leopard crawl survivalists use
the foxw walk and Ninjutsu teaches
techniques such as enu bashiri walking
like a dog and kitsui bashiri walk of
the
fox generally these movement patterns
focus on placing the foot or hand down
gradually first using just the ball of
the foot or the blade and then gradually
transferring weight the knees will
generally remain bent whilst walking to
allow for this easier transfer
Force Adam if you want to move more
quietly remember to keep your legs bent
this not only lets you absorb the impact
through your knees but also giv you
better balance so you can control your
free leg control my free leg exercises
like the 100 up major and minor the
anterior reach and one-legged Romanian
deadlifts can be great for developing
this kind of control control rooking is
a great exercise too this kind of
control try holding a while walking wait
what we're talking about extremely slow
movements here to completely eradicate
sound you might need to move at a
painstaking crawl so now I'm going to
demonstrate for you how you can land
really lightly from a drop or a jump to
absorb that impact with your knees so as
not to create much sound it's just a
shame we don't have anyone else to help
demonstrate
it Liam oh how you doing man hey bro
weird yeah strange how you doing yeah
good you f to be in the video yeah
always nice one let's go so I've
actually brought a sound meter with me
today and that's going to record and
display the amount of noise we're making
in decibels so I'm going to jump down
from here now and land noisily and then
I'm going to do the same thing again
whilst absorbing the impact with my
knees and feet and you should be able to
see the
difference fortunately I've also brought
Liam with me today who's much better at
this sort of stuff so he's going to have
a go
now that was quite now
not am I allowed to jump in any fashion
yes of course
yeah so if I was going to minimize my my
sound I would always get as low as I can
first and bounce up shoot my legs
out so they're ready to extend and ex
set the floor like that so this is like
the name let's come down in this
position here so it's like fully
extended absorb absorb absor AB
so you're lengthening your leg by doing
that so you've got more space to absorb
the impact yeah exactly cuz if I was to
just jump up I mean like if I just jump
like
this I've got way less I'm just like
there to there to absorb but if I can go
from this to this then it's like way
softer I'm going to have to go that now
yeah yeah nice man to Aid with this I
also am actually wearing barefoot shoes
right now these ones are from Vivo
Barefoot who didn't sponsor this video
but they often do work with me for
disclosure these are minimal shoes that
have a thinner Sole and wider toe box
that allows me to feel the ground better
and to much more easily absorb the
impact with the balls of my feet Liam
always wears minimal Footwear as well
yeah nice one so another way that you
can practice this kind of what what I
like to call strength finesse is with
something called quasi isometrics quasi
isometrics are movements performed
you're not completely static as with a
regular isometric instead you're moving
extremely slowly such that it almost
looks like an isometric hold but it's
actually Dynamic so for example you
might perform a push-up that takes you a
whole minute to complete or you might
perform a squat or a pull-up this is an
entirely different kind of challenge
than exploding into that movement
because when you do this not only does
it become something of an endurance
Challenge and a mental challenge which
we'll get to more in a moment but at the
same time your controlling and deciding
how many mootor units which muscle
fibers to engage in that
movement so I don't want to engage all
of my larger motor units all of my fast
switch fibers at once and explode
through the movement I need to gradually
add the smallest gradation of force by
calling upon those additional smaller
motor units the amount of neural control
and awareness that this can build can be
quite incredible if you use it as a
regular part of your
training
if you notice a little burst of speed at
the bottom there to get out of that
deepest position of the pistol squat
that's something that I shouldn't need
to do if I had complete total body
control I should be able to move my
weight in any position and this is
something we can train by incorporating
quas symmetrics into our workouts try
very slowly performing a pull-up very
slowly pulling yourself up onto a wall
and you should be able to develop the
ability to move with awareness precision
and quietness you see that shake King at
the point of failure that's my larger
motor unit my fastest twitch muscle
Fiers kicking in so with that movement
the amount of force I require and speed
doesn't necessitate the use of the
larger motor units I'm calling upon the
smaller ones and adding them because
they represent a more incremental change
at the point I start shaking I'm calling
upon those faster motor units the larger
motor units because I fatigued the
smaller ones and so that shaking is
actually the largest step change in
power output that loss of finesse that
comes when I start using those bigger
increases in
power as well as being aware of where
your own body is in space you also need
to be aware of where the enemy are you
need to know not only their positions
you need to think in terms of their
psychology what are they seeing where's
their line of sight and what is it
precisely that's going to give away your
location so here we're talking about
fieldcraft principles and the precise
list very depending on the organization
but some things to be aware of some
reasons that we be seen include spacing
silhouette Shadow shine or Texture and
movement so spacing being the space
between you and the other people on your
team Shadow being the shadow you cast
which of course you need to be aware of
As you move silhouette being the
silhouette that you form your shape
against the Horizon you need to think
about what's behind you as well as where
they are what are they seeing behind you
a white Open Sky for example is not
going to provide the same cover the same
kind of information scrambling as having
a busy dense background behind you you
need to think as well about things like
the Horizon and straight lines even if a
tiny piece of you is poking out over the
top of something you're hiding behind
this might not seem like a big deal but
because you're breaking that otherwise
straight line it actually stands out a
mile off and an enemy sniper can easily
take that shot what's also very
important is to consider your Shadow if
your casting along Shadow then even if
your body is hidden this could still
give away your
position there's another reason that we
also can use isometrics in training to
be like Solid Snake and that's because
it trains us to be comfortable being
uncomfortable this is what a member of
my Discord server an xmarine Corps
sniper told me that he had to use
isometrics for extremely long durations
hours and sometimes up to a day wearing
a weighted ruck sack and just
maintaining the same grueling position
patience and endurance is a huge part of
stealth if you imagine crawling into a
room or a bush and watching a Target you
could be there for an hour you could be
there for 2 hours you could be there for
a whole day and you need to have the
mental toughness to stay in that
position and to maintain that
cover so we spent absurd amounts of time
in push-up position or in a squat with
full gear and different surfaces and
conditions added layers of difficulty
like deep mud in the surf on rocks in
sand while raining in the cold Etc we
also spent time crawling and lying still
while remaining focused which is like
ADHD nightmare fuel by time I mean like
whole days spending 24 plus hours alone
in silence without moving while
remaining focused it takes a lot of
discipline luckily stuff like that was
less common than the movies make it out
I will note that this is not something
most people can effectively do alone at
first the brain and body will Rebel when
you get to your perceived limits and
it's going past those limits that has
the biggest effect Group Training is the
best way that I know of to force
yourself past these Comfort zones and
deep into what we call an existential
Peach
is that moment we'd start to ask if any
of this is worth it or are we completely
insane for signing up for this it's
important to note at this point the
incredible hard work and commitment of
those professionals what we're doing
here is Ling it's cool and fun and has
functional carryover to other skills but
we shouldn't mistake it for the real
deal huge respect to anyone who's
actually gone through this stuff and a
massive thank you to the members of my
Discord server and of my Facebook group
who contributed some of their knowledge
it's not just toughness mental toughness
and endurance we're training here it's
also important to remain calm and
focused for one obviously if you don't
remain calm then your panting and heavy
breathing your heart rate it's all going
to help to give you away and give away
your position but at the same time
remaining calm allows you to focus more
and to see and hear more your working
memory is actually crucial for
situational awareness your working
memory being your ability to store
information that you're working with we
don't just use this to store numbers we
use it to store information about the
space around us so of course if your
working memory is blunted you're going
to be less aware of what's going on
around you this is sometimes referred to
as Sports Vision or athletic vision and
it's something I've discussed at length
in other videos even being fortunate
enough to try some cool VR brain
training apps that usually are reserved
for pro athletes and Special Forces
another drill that the same user
recommended was counting objects whil
jogging and categorizing them for
example if you're running you might
count the number of red cars the number
of push chairs and the number of lamp
posts not not only does this force you
to remain aware of your surroundings
during taxing physical exercise it also
requires you to store multiple
categories of information a perfect task
for training working memory and you
might have noticed that it's very
similar to my free brain training app
biomind you can still get that from the
site by the way something we had to do
while in our hiding spot was memorize
the terrain around us using different
visual techniques to best judge
distances and sizes of features so we
could draw a map and having that
awareness while moving into position
also helped in this working memory
unfortunately also gets severely
dampened by activation of the
sympathetic nervous system when you
become very panicked when you go into
fight or flight mode this shuts down the
activity in the frontal cortex making it
harder for you to concentrate to stay
calm and to consider all the information
available to you so remaining in those
positions and remaining calm is
extremely important we're training here
is something called psychomotor
vigilance and friend of the channel J
Santana explain to me how he used this
when training not only top athletes but
also SEAL Team Six so what he'd have
them do is to perform a highly stressful
cardio activity whether it's pushing a
truck or whether it's using the stair
master and then immediately after that
he would follow that up with a
cognitively demanding task that would
require extreme Focus so here he'd be
chasing them in his case with pool
noodles and getting them to run away and
not allow him to touch them
alternatively you could use dual endb
training or biomine any kind of brain
training particularly one that Focus on
working memory but whilst you're in that
fatigued and aroused State and by doing
this you can train yourself to stay
alert even when you're tired even when
you're stressed a cool technique you can
use to improve your situational
awareness and at the same time to try
and stay calm is something called wide
angle Vision also known as ow eyes also
known as splatter Vision these are all
names for the same thing it's used by
survivalists it's used by Intelligence
Officers for scanning the environment
around them but I actually learned it
from what Wu karate so the idea is that
you're going to engage your peripheral
vision instead of having a narrow focus
in the center of your vision you're
going to be observing the area around
you in the corners the extremes of what
you can see when you do this it has a
couple of effects firstly it means you
can actually see more you taking more
information of course because you have a
wider focus at the same time this wider
angle of view also helps you calm your
central nervous system this is because
when we're aroused when we're in a state
of fight or flight our sympathetic
nervous system kicks in and this
actually causes our vision to narrow we
have a more narrow Focus conversely when
your parasympathetic nervous system
kicks in when you're allowed to relax
you now have a wider area of focus and
this connection works both ways so not
only do you see more when you're relaxed
but by seeing more you can actually
cause yourself to become more relaxed it
actually increases reflexes because the
information in the periphery of your
vision actually reaches your brain
faster it even improves your other
senses like your hearing because your
senses are very tightly connected in
your brain if you want to try it
yourself then you can use the method
that I learned from Karate take your
hands put them below you on top of each
other raise them slowly like this and
then draw a big circle starting from the
top and what you're doing is as you do
that you're watching both hands move
around now just maintain that peripheral
focus and explore your
environment in that
manner that said according to the
patreon member one way we can
incorporate some of that psychological
element is to seek out activities that
would normally cause that fight ORF
flight response whether that be bungee
jumping or cliff diving or something
else and using philosophy metacognition
and whatever other methods you need to
cope with it he also emphasizes the
importance of follow-up actions therapy
meditation journaling and support
activities to actually recover from this
inherently traumatic training just as
the muscles need to recover so too does
the
mind to truly become Solid Snake you
would need some intensely gruelling
training that would take a huge toll on
both your body and mind but with that
said we can certainly improve our body
awareness our ability to move quietly
and our situational awareness to some
degree the following are just some
exercises that you can add to your
current workout that will help you to
achieve just that quasi isometric lizard
crawls quasi isometric push-ups to
failure quasy isometric squats to
failure quasi isometric pull-ups to
failure super set to jump rope and dual
end back training stealth Landing
practice breakall practice and
rucking Adam remember creeping around
like this can be hard on the knees so
try to incorporate some atg split squats
or similar atg split squats or similar
remember training the cars tibialis
anterior and hip stability is also
useful also
useful weighted squat jumps are
excellent for learning to produce power
but also for learning how to absorb a
heavy impact
a heavy impact generally practicing
calisthenics moves such as handstands
and levers is another way to hone your
body awareness and control by the way
guys if you like this kind of training
that looks at Advanced Techniques to go
beyond simply building size and strength
you might enjoy my ebook and training
program super functional training 2.0
that's a program designed to build
strength size speed endurance mobility
and more all at once even cognitive
function the program is designed to sue
any level of experience and can be
adapted to use minimal equipment it
comes with over 2 hours of instructional
footage and an 80 plus page ebook I'll
leave a link in the description down
below so that is how you can train to
move a bit more like solid snake with
precision and control in order to move
quietly I recommend you incorporate
using some quasi isometrics into your
training I recommend that you
incorporate using some cardio in order
to challenge your psychomotor vigilance
in combination with brain training tasks
if you do all these things then you
might just become Solid Snake bye for
now while I don't recommend actually
hacking into high-tech facilities why
not put those computer skills to use by
building a website in fact even if you
don't have many computer skills to speak
of you'll still have no problem thanks
to today's sponsor
Squarespace Squarespace is a website
building platform that makes the process
of building modern stunning responsive
websites extremely simple you can start
by picking a template and then drag and
drop elements customize text and colors
and generally edit the site to look just
how you want it the whole process can be
over in 10 minutes and then you're ready
to go from there you can then update
your audience with Advanced formatting
and Publishing tools integrate your
social media channels for a steady flow
of content or generate Revenue using
members only gated content there's a
fully featured commenting system with
threaded comments replies and likes and
of of course fully functional e-commerce
tools and if you want to expand the
capabilities of your website even
further there's a huge selection of
plugins from the community and from
Squarespace themselves to choose from
for example if you want to enhance your
e-commerce then you can add things like
global Shipping Inventory management and
tax
reconciliation whether you're someone
who's just looking to build a basic
website in a few minutes to start
expressing yourself or you want to build
a fully functional website for your
business Squarespace has all the tools
you could
need
if you want to find out more then go to
squarespace.com and when you're ready to
launch head to squarespace.com
bioner for 10% of your first domain or
website thanks again to Squarespace for
sponsoring this video and bye for
now